Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Ucak. Ich bin aus dieser Station als Arzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Ich werde Ihnen gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen, bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen. Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich, bitte.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Paul Erlich.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Emil, Heinrich, Richard, Ludwig, Ida, Samuel, Cesar, Herr Heinrich.
Ok. Herr Erlich. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
18.9.1957
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter und 80.
Und wie schwer sind Sie so seit?
Ich bin 65 Kilo.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Herr Sanatci.
Danke für die Informationen. Herr Erlich, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zurzeit?
Ich habe starke Kopfschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich diese Schmerzen, Doktor.
Wo genau diese Schmerzen? Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen lokalisieren? Ich meine am ganzen Kopf oder einer Seite?
Die Kopfschmerzen sitzen hinter den Augen.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind Sie eher drückend oder dumpf?
Die Schmerzen sind steckend, Doktor.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Langsam aufgetreten, aber ich habe starke Schmerzen jetzt, Doktor.
Ich verstehe. Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichten, 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich würde die Schmerzen von 8 bis 9 bewerten, Doktor.
Herr Erlich, das ist eine sehr starke Schmerzenkala. Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben oder können Sie noch ein bisschen diese Schmerzen bis Ende des Sprechs aushalten?
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie mir eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Darf ich fragen, haben Sie eine Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ich habe keine Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente. Nein.
Oder leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen wie zum Beispiel Nierenversagen?
Nein.
Alles klar. Schwester Müller, geben Sie den Patienten eine Schmerzmittel?
Herr Erlich, fühlen Sie sich besser oder?
Ja, ich fühle mich jetzt sehr gut. Danke schön, Doktor.
Sehr gerne, das freut mich. Herr Erlich, haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja Doktor, ich habe so aus zwei Mal Aspirin 100 mg genommen, aber das hat nichts gebracht.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden, also früher gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste Problem für mich.
Ok, und waren Sie schon bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen, ich meine wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Ich bin nicht kein Arzt gewesen Doktor, auch habe ich vor zwei Tagen diese Beschwerden.
Herr Erlich, leiden Sie unter Schwinden?
Ich habe keine Schwinden Doktor.
Leiden Sie unter Sehstörungen oder Hörstörungen?
Nein, ich habe keine bemerkt, aber dazu kommt ein brennendes Gefühl im Hals, besonders beim Schlucken feste Nahrung Doktor.
Ok, also sind diese Beschwerden, ich meine Schluckstörungen, auch seit zwei Tagen da, richtig?
Ja, seit zwei Tagen oder drei Tagen.
Ok, haben Sie ein Druckgefühl, besonders im Stirn?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Ok, bleiben Sie unter Nackensteifigkeit?
Ich habe keine Nackensteifigkeit Doktor, nein.
Das freut mich. Fühlen Sie sich fieberig, Herr Erlich?
Ja Doktor, ich habe Fieber, meine Lebenspartnerin hat das Fieber gemessen und gestern hatte ich Fieber 39,2 Grad und ich fühle mich insgesamt schlafen und krasslos Doktor.
Ok, Herr Erlich, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit mit irgendjemanden kontaktiert, der erkältet ist?
Ich habe nicht erinnert, aber es ist möglich.
Ok, also hat Ihre Lebenspartnerin auch diese Beschwerden?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Schterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß, nein.
Schterfrost haben Sie?
Ich habe keine Schterfrost.
Ok, Herr Erlich, haben Sie eine Vergrößerung am Hals bemerkt?
Ich sehe nicht, aber ich denke, ich habe diese Probleme Doktor.
Ok, alles klar. Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, außerdem ist mir übel.
Mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein, ich habe keine erbrechen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich keinen Appetit.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, ich denke, wegen des Fiebers.
Verstehe. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirkulich abgenommen?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt. Ich bin immer gleich gewischt.
Ok, Herr Erlich, leiden Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Ja Doktor, ich habe auch Husten.
Ist der Husten trocken oder mit dem Auswurf?
Ich habe auch Husten mit gelb-weißem Auswurf Doktor.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot?
Luftnot, nein, ich habe keine Luftnot.
Ok, Herr Erlich, haben Sie Blut im Ausfluss bemerkt?
Ich habe keine Blut im Ausfluss bemerkt Doktor.
Ok, ok.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Schlafen Sie gut? Nein Doktor, seit zwei Tagen habe ich Fieber und Husten und Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe schlecht geschlafen.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Also haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Beide Doktor.
Ok, ok. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Sturmgang?
Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt Sturmgang- oder Wasserlassprobleme.
Ok, sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten oder Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig gegen Corona geimpft.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit besonders ins Ausland eine Reise gemacht?
Nein, ich bin nicht ins Ausland gegangen.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja Doktor, ich habe einige Vorerkrankungen. Seit meiner Kindheit habe ich Asthma. Dann nehme ich eine Zalbutomol-Spray.
Bei Bedarf ja?
Ja, bei Bedarf ja.
Vor 18 Jahren hatte ich eine Zepsis und dabei kam eine Herzmuskelentzündung. Seitdem habe ich eine Schwäche und nehme täglich Lersanidipin und bei Bedarf ein Diagnostikum Doktor.
Kennt ihr die Dosierung von Lersanidipin?
Keine Ahnung.
Keine Sorge. Ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren. Wie oft nehmen Sie ein Lersanidipin?
Bei Bedarf einmal täglich.
Einmal täglich, morgens oder abends?
Ja, morgens.
Und Sie nehmen Diagnostikum bei Bedarf ein?
Ja, bei Bedarf ja.
Kennen Sie den Namen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es ist.
Alles klar. Sonst haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck seit vier Jahren und dagegen nehme ich Romypril 10 mg täglich morgens.
Alles klar. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte mit vier Jahren eine Leistungsdruckoperation auf der rechten Seite.
Alles klar. Das war es, oder?
Nein. Vor 14 Jahren wurde mir die Kalend-Place entführt.
Auch ohne Komplikationen.
Das freut mich.
Nehmen Sie außer genannten Medikamenten noch irgendwelche anderen Medikamente ein?
Ich habe jetzt viele Medikamente ein. Ich habe gesagt, Doktor.
Außer keine Medikamente.
Alles klar. Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich bin gegen einige Dinge allergisch. Weil ich Kibbe und Äpfel habe.
Wie äußern sich diese Allergien?
Davon bekomme ich meistens Halsschnupfen, manchmal aber auch Durchfall.
Durchfall und?
Halsschnupfen.
Halsschnupfen?
Ja.
Okay. Herr Herrlich, rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider Doktor. Ich rauche seit etwa 18 Jahren wieder. Aber nur ein bis drei Zigaretten am Tag.
Früher waren es deutlich mehr. Fast 30 Jahre lang eine ganze Schachtel täglich.
Aber Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, das Traum zu reduzieren. Herr Herrlich. Okay.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig?
Aber ich denke, es wäre besser, wenn ich den Zigaretten aufhören würde.
Ja, also wenn Sie möchten, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen. Okay?
Ja, danke schön Doktor.
Gerne. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Alkohol trinke ich auch regelmäßig. Bis zwei Glas Wein am Abend.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, Drogen nehme ich keine Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich. Herr Herrlich, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Meine Mutter ist mit 88 Jahren an Nierenversagen und nach einem Schlaganfall gestorben.
Mein Vater hatte vor acht Jahren einen Herzinfarkt und bekam einen Beifass.
Er lebt jetzt in Altenheim, Doktor.
Okay, mein Beilag für Ihre Mutter. Ja. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Geschwister, aber sie sind gesunken.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, Doktor. Ich war zweimal verheiratet und lebe jetzt mit meinen lebernden Partnern zusammen. Ja.
Aber wie lange?
Ich habe fünf gesunken.
Okay. Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Früher war ich Schirrur, jetzt bin ich Averranter.
Okay. Alles klar. Herrlich, das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor. Was habe ich? Ich habe starke Kopfschmerzen, Husten, Hausschmerzen und Müdigkeit. Was habe ich?
Herrlich, es ist früh, etwas genau zu sagen, aber ich vermute, dass Sie an einer oberen Atemwegeinfektion leiden.
Also das bedeutet, Sie haben eine Lungenentzündung oder nur eine oberen Atemwegeentzündung.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Okay. Also sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen. Okay?
Okay. Ich gerne wissen, Doktor, ob ich in einem Krankenhaus bleibe oder gehe ich nach meinem Haus.
Also ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können und eine Therapie anordnen können.
Aber wenn wir etwas auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen. Herrlich.
Ist es gefährlich, diese Beschwerden, diese Krankheit oder?
Herrlich, ohne Therapie kann diese Beschwerden gefährlich sein, aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus und Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen. Wir werden alles für Sie tun. Okay?
Okay. Danke schön, Doktor.
Sehr gerne.
Ich warte auf Sie. Danke.
Ich bin gleich wieder da. Okay?
Okay. Okay, Doktor.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Paul Ehrlich ist 68 Jahre alt, 1,80 Meter groß und 65 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Ehrlich, stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehender Cephalgie sowie produktiver Zusiss mit dem gelblichen und weißen Schuputum vor.
Ja, und der Patient berichtete über den Patienten zufolge, seien die Cephalgie langsam aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf eine Schmerzskala 8 bis 9 von 10 bewertet und die Einnahme von zweimaligen Astrien, 100 Milgramm, hätte keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen stichend seien. Die Fragen nach ähnlichen Beschwerden, vertigo, Sechsstörungen, Höchstörungen wurden verneint.
Der Patient klagte über Pyrexie bis zu 39,2 Grad Celsius und berichtete über auch Fatigue, Asthenie und Halsschmerzen beim Schlucken.
Die Fragen nach Nackensteifigkeit und Dyspnoe wurden verneint. Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Nausea ohne Emesis, Schmerzbedingte Inappetenz, Schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Einschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und viermal Covid-19 geimpft und die Reise an Amnese wurde verneint.
Anfängerkrankungen nannte er seit Kindheit bestehende Asthma-Bronchialle, seit vier Jahren bestehende Arzellhypertonie und vor 18 Jahren diagnostizierte Sepsis.
Der Patient nehme Lersanidipin und die Urethika gegen Myokalpitis, die nach der Sepsis aufgetreten sei und er nehme auch Ramiplil 10 mg morgens ein.
Er benutze Salbutamol Spray bei Bedarf. Mit vier Jahren sei er wegen einer Harnia Inguinalis rechts operiert worden und vor 14 Jahren sei bei ihm eine Cholestectomie durchgeführt worden.
Er habe Allergie gegen Walnüsse, Kiwi und Apfel, die sich durch Renitis und Diarrhoea äußern.
Er sei Raucher und er rauche 1 bis 3 Zigaretten täglich seit 18 Jahren. Davor habe er eine Schachter Zigaretten täglich 30 Jahre lang geraucht.
Er trinke 1 bis 2 Gläser Wein abends und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater vor acht Jahren an Myokalpinfarkt gelitten und bei ihm eine Bypassoperation durchgeführt worden sei.
Er wohnt im Moment in einem Altenheim. Die Mutter hat mit 88 Jahren an Niereninsuffizienz verstorben und sie habe an Apoplex gelitten.
Der Patient hat zwei gesunde Geschwister und er hat zweimal geheiratet und hat fünf gesunde Kinder und wohnt mit seiner Partnerin.
Er sei Rentner, aber früher habe er als Chirurg gearbeitet.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Pneumonie aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter Prodiktivartussis mit gelblichen weißlichen Sputum, Pyrexie bis zu 39,2,
Cephalgie, Halsschmerzen, Müdigkeit, also Fatigue. Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Pneumonie.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen Covid-19-Infektionen, obere Atemwegeinfektionen, Epstein-Bavirus-Infektionen in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, also Cyanose, vergrößerte Lymphknoten, Infiltration, feuchte Rassergeräusche bei der Asfiltration.
Und vermehrte Klopfen.
Welche Werte sind wichtig bei der Vitaparameter?
Wir sollen Atemfrequenz, Herzfrequenz und Sauerstoffsättigung überwachen.
Das Wichtigste ist die Sauerstoffsättigung. Wenn es ein Problem mit der Sauerstoffsättigung gibt, sollen wir den Patienten sobald Sauerstoff geben.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Leukocytunsal, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten, Leid der Dümere bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine zweiebene Röntgenuntersuchung, Röntgen des Thorax durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen.
Bei der Röntgenuntersuchung können wir Infiltration feststellen bei der Pneumonie.
Danach würde ich eine gegebenenfalls Ct des Thorax durchführen, um die Gewebepathologie zu überprüfen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen. Der Patient ist 68 Jahre alt.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall Spirometry durchführen?
Spirometry können wir bei den Patienten durchführen.
Das ist keine Notfallmaßnahme, aber können wir nach der Station eine Spirometry durchführen, um die Lungenfunktionen zu beurteilen.
Machen Sie in diesem Fall Brokkoskopie?
Normalerweise habe ich eine Verdacht auf Pneumonie. Aber wenn wir als Verdachtdiagnose eine Lungenkarzinom haben, können wir eine Brokkoskopie durchführen.
Gehen Sie weiter?
Zunächst würde ich den Patienten einen venösen Zugang legen und ich würde den Patienten sofort Antibiotika, Analgetikum verabreichen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich einen Pneumonologischen Konsil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit dieser geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
In welchem Fall würden Sie stationär aufnehmen?
Es gibt einen Scope 65. Wir werden diese Score berechnen. Über 65 ist ein Punkt, ein Score.
Blutdruck ist auch wichtig.
Wenn der Blutdruck systolischer über 90, diastolischer über 50 bedeutet, ist das auch ein Punkt.
Und Urea ist auch wichtig. Über 7 mm. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, Herr Oberst.
Aber wir sollen diese Score berechnen und wenn der Patient 1 bis 2 Punkte hat, dann sollen wir den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Wenn der Patient 3 bis 4 Punkte hat, sollen wir den Patienten intensiv stationär aufnehmen.
Herr Kollegen, können Sie uns Bronchoscopy aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über Bronchoscopy aufklären.
Bronchoscopy ist die endoskopische Untersuchung der Atemwege.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Tumore oder andere Veränderungen der Atemwege genau zu erkennen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung schieben wir einen dünnen flexiblen optischen Schlauch durch den Mund oder durch die Nase bis in den Bronchen vor.
Diese Untersuchung kann sowohl zu diagnostischen als auch therapeutischen Zwecken benutzt werden.
Also während dieser Untersuchung können wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen oder kleine Tumoren entfernen.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 30 Minuten und dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Kontraindikationen, aber es gibt einige Komplikationen wie z.B. Nachblutungen oder Verletzungen der Schleimhäute.
In der Regel geben wir den Patienten ein leichtes Schlafmittel.
Nach der Untersuchung darf der Patient keine wichtigen Sachen machen wie z.B. selbst Autofahren oder wichtige Verträge zu unterschreiben.
Der Patient soll eine Begleitperson mitbringen, die den Patienten nach Hause bringt.
Was machen Sie während der Untersuchung der Patienten übergeben?
Wir machen eine lokale Betäubung.
Der Patient muss vor der Untersuchung nicht sterben.
Der Patient soll ca. 6 Stunden nicht sterben.
Weil wir den Patienten Schlafmittel geben.
Wozu werden wir die Gewebeprobe schicken?
Für histologische Untersuchungen werden wir die Gewebeprobe zur Histologieabteilung schicken.
Welche anderen Pathologien können wir gleichzeitig behandeln während der Bronchoscopy?
Wenn es ein fremder Körper im Atemweg gibt, können wir diesen fremder Körper entnehmen.
Ja, richtig.
Unsere Zeit ist um.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Aber ich glaube, Herr Dr. Puppil hat für uns extra Zeit gemacht.
Herr Kollege, können Sie uns Spirometrie aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über Spirometrie aufklären.
Spirometrie ist eine Untersuchung der Luftfunktionen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung hilft uns die Atemwegeprobleme, wie zum Beispiel Asthma, Rundschelle oder COPD,
um die Atemwege genau zu erkennen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung benutzt der Patient eine Probe einzuatmen.
Mundstück?
Mundstück, um tief einzuatmen und auszuatmen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung prüfen wir die Geschwindigkeit und die ...
Erste Sekunde?
Erste Sekunde, totale Atmung.
Ich konnte die richtige Worte nicht finden, Herr Oberarzt.
Mit einer Klammer auf die Nase soll der Patient tief einatmen und ausatmen.
Bei der Untersuchung sollen wir die Geschwindigkeit der Atmung und die Menge zu überprüfen.
Dafür braucht der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Komplikation oder Kontraindikationen bei dieser Untersuchung.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Anverschränkungen und der Patient kann seinen Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Herr Kollegen, ich denke unsere Prüfung ist beendet.
Gehen Sie in die Info-Desk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg in Ihrem Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe das Volumen nicht in der Hand.
Sie können es in Englisch sagen.